[Music]
[Applause]
I'm Gary O'Reilly and I'm Chuck nice
this is playing with science today we
entered Twitter 'dom through the vast
multiverses of neil degrasse tyson's
mind and light up the cerebral smears
that engage with a complex and
ever-evolving world of sport yeah
so did you did you change your meds
because this like any other grass tyson
has many opinions and many things which
he chooses to share on a regular basis
but he has a heartfelt connection to
sports that constantly filtered through
his scientific lens on twitter so when
you play with science there can be no
better play date than the man him yes
thanks for joining us right now it's the
one the only the inevitable
[Music]
like that scared that's not the gong oh
my god normally that's how you get
someone off the stage right I saw the
gong show all righty now don't take it
personally no that is a that is a royal
entrance right there that's what the
dawn is for now normally I'm sitting
there that's right sir now you just took
you just took your own damn show kind of
now I'm a guest on your damn show
leading you out comfortably okay okay
I'll get used to it that's all right it
doesn't happen without you no matter
what though what's up it's going to
start asking us questions you want
better help him say no I mean happily be
your guest on this yeah that's there
please don't ask us any questions I feel
loved
yes I feel loved that's very cool thanks
for being here man well right yet it and
of course you are a prolific tweeter
yeah but it's not well so a couple
things first I said I have many opinions
which I do but I hardly ever tweet
opinions this is true most opinionated
tweet I ever posted which was clearly an
opinion was after star wars the force
awakens I said bb-8 is way cuter than
r2d2 right clearly an opinion I could
append and of course there are fights
and things you kidding me yeah those
generational fights yeah without and but
what I try to is not give you an opinion
because frankly I don't care if you
share my opinion on anything okay what I
care is that whatever opinion you come
up with it is informed with objectively
verifiable truths nice yeah there you go
this man is always about science
education right right there it is a
tweet they make whatever old damn
opinion you want right I don't care but
I mean I cared broadly but specifically
person-to-person right just I'll give
you more information that you may have
had before right to help you understand
your decision so it's funny so a healthy
universe thank you I like that I'm
representing the universe in my presence
here today and the funny thing when you
talk about opinions and I caught the
tail end eavesdropping of you having a
conversation with somebody you were
saying that when scientists talk to
people if you say things that are just
patently unscientific or just false or
false yeah and you just refuse you just
you just you just
blindly adhere to those things yeah
we're not going to argue with you just
walk away
it is why the way yeah yeah there's the
old adage which is mostly true right
that if an argument last more than five
minutes then both sides are wrong
ha ha ha the time line on the Ottoman
I'm not a fan about you know you think
about it yeah because facts are facts
and you know yeah and by the way in
science is not like we don't argue but
when we argue we argue with a certain
fundamental premise which perhaps does
not exist with other kinds of arguments
other spheres of argument in science you
and I argue it's built on the premise
that either I'm right and you're wrong
right or you're right and I'm wrong or
we're both wrong right and the fact that
we're arguing is that there's
insufficient data to resolve this yet
right so we use our arguments to help
shape what next data we're going to put
on the table so that we can get over
with that argument agree and go on to
the next problem right but the argument
in science is not for the sake of
argument but like I know I am but what
are you I know you are but what am I
your mama right you know I need 9
percent of the normal log right it's
really a nice there are no your momager
right no your manager I think a good
thing that would be fine if I get up and
give a talk at a scientific conference
and somebody doesn't like it yo mama I'd
have no rebuttal to that right actually
so what would I what we're talking about
today are the tweets of Niels with
respect to sports which is you called
all my my sports tweets would get my
friendly they're not it's not I mean I
just a few but it's not like that's what
I do right no but there's this there's
more than 40 of them 40 and we have able
to 5,000 okay so there's one in a
hundred is a sports 100 is a sports
tweet right and a lot of times they
surround very significant sporting event
yes yes just to keep it in the mood
right you know it's like this is a ball
or the ellipse is your gray matter
yes it is one in a hundred and you are
an athlete you know I mean 40 pounds ago
yes I think we've established where all
everyone here is an exactly so you know
I'm sure that you know your person who
looks at
so when as a former athlete you were a
wrestler did you catch I since we're
like three guys here all right so you
know where my how how I wear my 40
pounds so a lot of it is everywhere but
of course we're guys so most of it just
goes to the bed right I've always had
broad shoulders and a large chest and my
chest even at my chubbiest was always
bigger than my waist so all you have to
do is cut a jacket to cut sport coat to
come in at the waist a little bit right
then it still cuts and you don't look
like some slob that you know that
clearly was once in shape but is no
longer a though so I've been able to
fake this extra weight in my in my next
week on playing with science we'll have
colors for spring and as well as
tailoring Dada
haberdashery advice from playing with
science you know we like to start off
every show with a clip of sport and clip
that do okay if again we have something
you made a you you wrote a tweet about
loosing ball I thought it was very cute
but speaking of loosing ball who by the
way for those of you who are interested
we are going to be doing a show with who
sampled who has expressed his it will
come on the show not know he was not to
you as you want to talk to me to do an
interview with you that we will then
take and put on the show oh okay yeah
and catch him yeah if we all look at
that you can't you that was good yeah
can't you good yeah so anyway he is the
fastest man in the world and probably
the greatest sprinter of all time and
here's a little ditty from him and
something called the real Olympics
Gatlin got a good enough start off as a
bit slighted again he's got to work
Gatlin's in front fault stretching out
now he's coming after him he's immortal
now yes a stunner gatlin challenge for
the silver medal 9.80 all the way from
Beijing to London and now to Rio it is
one of the greatest athletic
achievements of all time if not the very
greatest Wow
there you have it what was great about
so here's the way I gotta jump in right
now jump right in right now so he's not
the fastest man in the world he's the
fastest human there ever was Wow just to
be clear to thinks okay this is why we
have measuring devices implanted to say
pasa
one of the greatest know if he's the
fastest human there ever was it is the
greatest thank you
it's just it's not one of not about an
opinion that he that point these are
numbers that were just as a good thing
about the methods and tools of science
it renders opinions irrelevant okay
right so right so so I know where you
were going with that the winner of the
hundred meter dash is considered the
fastest man in the world right you set a
world record in it you're the fastest
person there ever was right everyone now
that's pretty cool okay think about it
oh you got my tweet tweet okay it's so
it's I really liked it you caught some
flak on this from some haters because
you used bolt the dog who by the way
great movie if you have kids which I do
young children I took them a few years
ago and it's a it's a - movie and it's
about a dog who's super super fast and
so why don't you read the tweet okay so
in this tweet this is not from memory
you have it up on a screen that I'm
looking at okay so I just thought people
should know how fast bolts are right I
said how many bolts can I come up with
so there's Usain Bolt there's a
lightning bolt right I thought I
remembered some other sort of cartoon
character bolt and sure enough there was
the dog from the movie hi so then I
looked up the speed the average running
speed of that species of dog okay
because there was a real species of dog
portrayed in the film I got all these
three numbers together and I put it in
metric units so here we go
as between 100,000 meters per second
lightning bolt a though yep
thirteen point four meters per second
bolt ten point four meters per second
hussein bolt same book and i and i
matched three images together one of the
lightning bolt the dog and hussein
that's all I did
and that's not an opinion here I've
given you information and so a lot of
people were incredulous that a human
being could run ten point four meters in
one second well they never they didn't
see it in this context right yeah
Chris because here's ten meters one
second is short ten meters is how far
you got to go in four downs to get a
first down sadly and they couldn't quite
people were like okay realization right
the time and distance becomes an issue
okay I did not know because I can't
track everybody's comment about it I I
read the comments after I read this and
a lot of people were like that's
impossible
ten so ten ten point four meters in one
second but it's over a hundred meters
right and in fact he doesn't look like
he didn't hit his stride until seventy
meters or so he doesn't he never does
he's still accelerating at 100 meters
yeah but that's the whole thing about
you saying boat against the shorter
sprinters he takes one or two steps less
okay so the power transference from when
his foot hits the track and then goes
here allows him to become that much
faster in the latter stages but probably
also more efficient cause he had takes
fewer steps to go the same way and the
experts are saying he may not be the
apex of human sprinting somebody is some
stage another outlier will turn up and
go even faster
well what that person will look like how
long any legs going to be he is really
fine the shape if you think of sprinters
in the past with little pocket rockets
yeah yeah he's come along at six foot
five but he's probably you remember the
great athlete Carl Lewis the of course
uh-huh he's probably five inches taller
core loses five ten or something oh yeah
six five yeah and much bigger yeah just
that much quicker yeah yeah so it was so
it was a delight to watch him run
of course I mean on TV I saw it but yeah
so yeah template so the m/s transfer of
of how to think about speed to whatever
extent that would have helped that's
great what concerns me is that we have
an educational system where someone
could think that's wrong yes that assert
that is wrong and which they did by the
way right don't rather than say wow I
never thought about it that way before
let me investigate to see if Tyson is
right rather than assert that I'm wrong
right cuz correct people just so you
know I think about this before I tweeted
this isn't that'll just like randomly go
let me throw down some numbers no no I
put way more thought into my tweet then
you will ever believe given how much
thought most people put into their
tweets don't put into the streets right
right so just just so you know the fact
is it's possible to run ten point four
meters per second right because a
100-meter dash takes 10 seconds
therefore it's 10 meters per second AUL
it was really simple math is math not
even 101 that's like the thing is I
think for a lot of people is like you
say you see 10 meters and you see one
second and you think of somebody coming
from a standing a handing position and
going one second and they've gone 10
meters right right that's that's the way
people do another another impasse in
this mental impasse occurred as trains
were getting faster mm-hmm
someone said Oh will we ever go a mile a
minute
Oh Sam I'll admit it I've never had
those in the same sentence before and
and hell that's just 60 miles an hour
all it is is 60 miles there's 60 minutes
in an hour a mile a minute hey there you
go and people and nobody would blink
twice at that right today because we
complain if you were doing 60 miles an
hour only 60 miles really train one of
the superstars trying to get Europe yeah
well that was great man that was it that
was really cool and I just love the fact
that no matter what you tweet it's
always controversial to someone but
that's not my I'm not trying to be
controversial by the way I have tweets
that I read I might say you know that's
probably controversial I'm not going to
tweet that one day I'm going to collect
all the ones that
I knew in advance would be controversial
and chose not to tweet them sweet okay
the day to dump them on the orbit with
data I said you think you think I'm
trying to be controversial the contrary
you have no idea here you go okay I
license new book of controversy yes I've
got to find a way to make that into a
book okay Neal toasted we got one here
at the world who's from the 2012
Olympics all right I said how about a
Mars Olympics yes all athletes would
suffocate ignoring that complication way
cooler than an earth Olympics that's all
ain't cooler than limpets I'm setting
you up for tweets that follow that was
going to say so yeah when you say way
cooler then you actually give us some
examples of why Olympics on Mars or
pretty much any sporting event on Mars
might be cool might also a couple
hundred degrees below zero on Mars so
way cooler has double meaning that I
think we pick them pick that up okay all
right so let's look at one of the Mars
tweets and this is cycling on Mars okay
all right I'll go ahead write so this is
again during the the summer 2012
Olympics if they were cycling on Mars
try Olympic Mons of volcanic Mountain
five times taller than Mont Blanc in the
Alps Wow so you think you've got tall
mountains here no the tallest mountains
and the deepest valleys are not on earth
that in the solar system there on Mars
they're on the moon so we ain't got
nothing right yeah we're not doing well
without winning those contests you know
this the atmosphere on Mars is how much
less than the Earth's atmosphere about
1/100 okay yeah so if we had pressure
atmospheric pressure so in other words
for every breath you take on Mars
there's 1/100 the amount of air in that
breath and it would be on an athlete
altitude becomes your enemy in terms of
the oxygenation if you're performing in
altitude but the ideal way to do this is
you train an altitude and they compete
at sea level right we need to do Serpas
yeah don't have any problem getting up
the mountain while all the tourists are
like good stretch all the baby tribe or
so here's what you do even though that's
right on now and make a suggestive never
been made before you ready here we go
you drain the Pacific Ocean okay oh then
hold the Olympics at the bottom of the
Marianas Trench
but you train at high altitude but now
you compete at the bottom which is a
trench six miles down now every breath
of air has way more oxygen right and at
sea level and so now you have heroic
feats before you don't even have to dope
your blood the air itself will put the
oxygen at the corset right into your
blog the ideas are going to stump up for
that draining in fact I don't say I just
like the fact that you're thinking like
a super villain yeah I'd have gone the
other way and if it goes so go trying on
Mouse mm-hmm on the on the mountain look
at moms and come back to us and compete
problem is it's only 40 percent the
gravity of Earth so you're the weight
that you are carrying is not as much
going up the hill yeah yeah right so
there is some trade-off some trade-offs
they just worried often related suits
saying oh yeah yeah just lead lead lead
yourself down
another thing once you've drain the
Pacific Ocean there's nothing to do with
sports just while we're on the topic if
you drain the Pacific Ocean that is the
great toilet bowl of dead satellites oh
really yes yeah because they always
splashdown in the Pacific
although they crash down and it's a bad
satellite they're not quite in that
class it down there guys yeah yeah so
the reason why is the Pacific Ocean is
almost 1/3 of all possible longitudes on
earth right so if you D orbit and you do
it you have a lot of latitude no pun
intended
to where you begin the deorbit so that
it's going to plunk down in Pacific I
wet and add people don't live there so
not over the great bulk of the expanse
ok so it's a safe place to drop your
stuff out of orbit the day we do orbit
Hubble it's going straight up and into
this yes the specific listen well and
it's a size of a Greyhound bus by the
way if you now know nice telescope
oh yeah this is one of my favorite okay
you know we actually talked about this
in in a different forum on Startalk and
it's swimming on Mars okay so here it is
again yeah the same same week if they
were swimming on Mars the low
temperature and low air pressure
would force the pool to simultaneously
freeze and boil sweet that how many
hours does Michael Phelps have to Train
coke with freezing and boiling I guess
because he's up to about 50,000 there it
is gurgling edited chunks of ice in
there as well so athletes at the same
time so can you explain that but so they
you know how you get to that how do you
get to that situation so in chemistry in
physics as well it's called the triple
point okay so which is a cool name
the aníbal point of a substance is the
point where it is happy being solid
liquid and gas or to Santa okay so now
now that sounds freaky because it's
outside of our common life experience
right but it's less so than you might
think one thing so take a look at dry
ice okay co2 that's in a double point of
its state so it is simultaneously a
solid and a vapor right it's happening
all at once yeah okay you open the thing
up the vapor comes out and is solid
right that's a double point it's occupy
that's not as interesting as a triple
point but it does make for awesome
concerts so here so here's I I use other
smoke for that rather I think there's
auto do they got that done he used to
use dry ice back in the day but you're
right they used smoke machines would be
years ago when Twisted Sister performed
and might in awk three no so so here's
how it works
you you know that when you go to high
altitude yeah
it affects cooking times because water
boils at a lower temperature right you
know this instead of 212 if we're all
using imperial units it could it could
boil at 200 degrees or 180 degrees you
have to increase the cooking time
because the food is not at the high
temperature for as long and you can't
get boiling water hotter than the
temperature that is boiling at right all
right one of the earliest experiments I
did with my kids so they understood this
you I would start boiling a pot of water
I say I give them a thermometer say
measure the temperature and it's like a
hundred degrees three minutes I have
measured again hundred ten degrees
hotter and why do you keep doing this
and I say there's heat going into it
they say yeah we see the flame my kids
like six since
an8 so then it's like 200 degrees they
check it again 205 210 212 okay 10
minutes later measured again - I little
212 where's the energy going alright oh
my gosh it stops going because water
cannot be liquid at that temperature and
at that air pressure right it's got to
become a gas right so now you lower the
air pressure the boiling point drops
right
and the more you lower the air pressure
the lower the boiling point drops right
and eventually the boiling point meets
the freezing point of water and now you
have frozen water liquid water in
boiling water almost and coolant that's
exactly right
awesome that's fantastic man that is
fantastic
alright so instead of getting into
another one why don't we because we're
up against a break let's take a break
and we'll come back with more oh I'm
going to do this one real quick I go
ahead okay
still Olympics on Mars Olympics on Mark
III I want to say because like my side
of my I caught it
okay I quarter my eye and I don't want
to we can pick it up after after the
break but I press go for it women's
beach volleyball on Mars no protective
ozone layer there solar UV would
irradiate all exposed legs buns and
tummies Wow then hardly wear clothes and
diamonds beach volleyball fit which is
you know that's why I don't watch it to
them very modest although you watch
doesn't leave alright soul is that break
we're in trouble break it we're going to
come back with more of Neil deGrasse
Tyson's tweets on sports right after
this
welcome back I'm Gary O'Reilly I'm Chuck
nice I know I was why are we here for
you here were your backup team and this
is playing with science we have no the
west Iceland where they've got to work
on that visit this is playing with
science okay go go reprimanded okay I
want to know knows I'm not yeah yeah and
now you want okay bonding the gun Butler
a servant he never lose an opportunity
praying with science and Neil deGrasse
Tyson is here with us and his tweets
he's many tweets and have opinions not
opinions but their Twitter before we
jump back into it I just realized
something so everyone's once when we
were talking about volleyball on Mars
burning the skin because you know no UV
protection yeah by the way the Mars is
farther away from the Sun than is earth
right so they was at one point for carry
the two don't you get it wrong you'll
get so Mars has about one-half this
solar intensity then does Mars so in any
given amount of time all other things
being equal it would take you twice as
long to get to get sunburned but Mars
does not have a UV layer right no zones
on there right because there's no free
oxygen on Mars right so on earth free
oxygen is the oxygen we breathe that's
Oh too right oxygen binds with itself
the ozone layer high up in the
atmosphere is three oxygen atoms and the
reason why that blocks UV and that you
ever no wonder why I did not okay so
this molecule is sitting there fat and
happy in the upper atmosphere okay and
one of its bonds that bind these
molecules together is the same
energetics as that of an ultraviolet
particle of light and ultraviolet photon
that's it ultra water photon comes in it
is just what it needs to bust it open
right so the energy of the light is gone
and it got converted to breaking apart
this molecule right so it's really eight
the UV molecule note that you'll be Pro
tight that that that actual molecular
bond becomes a natural block
like it's literally like a like a
blocking tab neural block and if there's
a very close explosion to us in our
solar system
okay supernova you can calculate because
it takes a while to regenerate the the
ozone alright because it's a stable
layer you win some you lose some
right re-manufactured Thank You Al Gore
okay so watch what happens so if you
have a near by supernova which has a lot
of UV the waves of UV light
take out your ozone and then the next
wave goes through without without
conflict Wow
so if the first way is just like an army
that's exactly like army wave waves of
armies and so the ozone can only protect
you so much before it has to rebuild
itself if you have a major flux of UV
coming in what's the timeline on a
rebuild I'd I have to calculate that I'd
okay it has many sources lightning can
actually regenerate you can put energy
back in to recreate this process because
different chemical reactions are
exothermic and endothermic and it's the
balance of all of these that creates the
chemists the chemical cocktail that is
our atmosphere nice so yes so other
mechanisms can be generated and I
whatever those mechanisms are you can
construct actual things in the universe
that will override them such as
supernova explosions yeah other planets
or moons in our solar system with a
similar ozone no because we get our
oxygen from life right I used to think
in Star Trek
Oh captain this is an oxygen nitrogen
atmosphere we can go down and breathe it
I said all we have to do is look around
the universe for a planet that had that
happens to have the the chemical mixture
that Earth has right then I realize no
it's not how it works it's not that
every planet's got its own mixture it's
that earth has oxygen because we have
life right because we because the the
photosynthesis all the the green plants
make that oxygen and that then it that's
like rocket fuel for animals then
animals can now rise up metabolize
oxygen and we have this harmony of
plants and animals
we just say hi so let's move on to some
other tweets and we're going to kind of
group these as you know kind of like to
deal with ice so think of it it's like
you know maybe skating on Enceladus or
oh robo or okay I'll be like that but
you you happen to have some some skating
facts that you tweeted about one if this
was during the Winter Olympics this is
February 2014 I totally remember the
dates okay okay so here's one of these
are you watching the Olympics in Sochi
loving me some Olympics oh I love me
some Olympics okay so I sit this is how
obscure fact okay by the way I tweet 125
characters not 140 you see now you're
just showing up every single by the way
uh pretty much every Tula you know I try
to leave the rare except starters I'd
like to leave characters on the table
just say in case I need them point yeah
just occasionally engineer them then the
bank in the character bracket okay
obscure fact skating is possible only
because compressed ice melts so skaters
glide on slippery water not on slippery
ice sweet so now are you saying that the
friction between the blade and the
either friction the pressure the
pressure yes between the blade and the
ice is melting the ice so that there is
an ever so thin layer of water that the
skater is actually gliding like a snail
makes its little visit loop next why me
a slimy goo I've never heard skating and
analogize to snails snail slime like
snail slime that's exactly yeah okay
Chuck yeah want to need a meds this
morning I don't know I think we're going
to share are you sure but now how is it
if this is this case oh so Incheon is
your back can we back up for a minute
yeah okay because I'm really fascinated
by this uh generally people's
understanding of the word force is
accurate to how we use it in physics
again generally they same yeah okay I
need more force to open this door okay
so you put in a force there's another
term called pressure mm-hmm which is
less familiar as a physics term in the
public okay
so pressure is force divided by the area
over which the force is operating at you
okay mm-hmm so so watch what happens if
I have a knife and it's not cutting
because it's dull I'm putting a force on
that knife and it's not working I you
have to ask yourself what is the area of
the cutting blade what is the area of
the thing that's touching the thing
you're trying to cut it's dull
so you may it's not very big you know
let's say it's one square millimeter
over the entire length of the blade
let's say okay okay now you sharpen the
blade what does that mean you're
reducing the surface area of the cutting
it now it's one hundredth of a square
millimeter because that stuff would you
can even it's this and now the force
divided by the area creates an enormous
pressure right so the lower the pressure
the lower the area is of that cutting
blade a higher the pressure the pressure
is for the same force that you're using
to cut that's why sharp knives cut
that's why it that's what it means when
you will sharpen a knife you're
shrinking the denominator of that
equation pressure equals force divided
by area so if you've ever ice skated I
used to I used to be a skating guard
actually okay long ago long ago and I
you figure skates by the way so so okay
so when they quote sharpen skates what
you do is you actually put a concave cut
up the bottom of the blade is concave
it's right okay out if you ever look
closely I I have a pixel on every day to
school day okay go to be they sawed it
so it's concave the full length of the
blade so that means if you lean to the
left or to the right all of your weight
is on basically a knife edge of the
skate and so that creates extreme
pressure on the ice and how thick is the
ice is like a fraction of an inch did
you know this
okay ice-skating rinks it's like a
fraction of an inch
day so now you put pressure on the top
of that ice and it melts the ice in the
instant your skate comes over Lao okay
now but I didn't explain why the ice
melts
that is one of the most profound facts
in the universe but are you are you
ready for I don't know if you're ready
for that down anyway so let's go okay
all right okay you ready okay so you
wish me now that the sharper the edge
I'll hire the pressure right okay you
got that all right so now we all know
that ice floats okay that is where among
material among substances usually if you
freeze something cool it and freeze it
to get smaller right right okay water
however expands when it gets to about
four degrees Celsius by the way water is
shrinking down to about four degrees
Celsius and not freezing at freezing
would be zero right
what do you Celsius then it says I'm now
going to get bigger right
so between four and zero right it
becomes puffier and it becomes less
dense than the water it's sitting on and
it floats okay that's why it is almost
impossible to completely freeze a lake
in the winter because if a chunk of ice
forms anywhere it floats and you will
freeze the top of your lake and that
will insulate the rest of the lake from
the cold temperatures that are above it
right I look at the temperature
basically prevents the bottom so all the
fish just get lower and lower and lower
and hang out until springtime and then
they come back right otherwise we would
be killing all life-forms in every lake
for every winter okay so now watch what
happens now I now have this ice cube
that is bigger in volume than they could
then what it's melted but then what it
would be melted right with you I want to
now squeeze that ice cube that's not
allowed
you can't do that because the ice has to
be that violent it that's it right it
has to be that volume to be ice so it
has to return yet oh yeah the same
before you throw this yeah it's me
it's got to turn back to water turn back
to water under pressure oh my god that
is so it's good okay okay
well no it's freaking it is a to wait in
the way wait wait wait wait wait let's
get the top where we will see that light
bulb which is not this is everything I
love hand brain orgasm this stuff have
the brain orgasm at this little brain
well guys it's up to wait wait I gotta
tell you okay wait so by the way go
ahead this is also why pipes break in
the winter right what happens water is
sitting there okay how come they don't
break at at all right so water sitting
there in the pipes now watch what
happens so the water tries to expand but
the pipe is preventing it right okay so
you can get down to 31 degrees no
nobody's pipes freeze at 31 degrees or
30 degrees you know the water is still
there contained okay then you reach a
point where the pressure of the pipe
can't make can't can't keep this thing
as water and the water changing state
becomes more powerful than the freakin
copper pipe itself that's right and it
says I am now Iceman right it busted out
of the pipe it'll break practically
anything but if you make something
that's kind of unbreakable it'll stay
water all the way down so check this out
with that in mind on there I love scotch
okay I enjoy drinking some scotch
great malt and they have these giant
copper weights and they are hollowed out
so that it says sphere on the inside of
this giant copper wasters in the VAT
where the well now wait a minute this is
for this is for our ice cube so that you
can make a ice cube to put in your
scotch now diluting your about diluting
your oh okay what they do is they take a
block of ice they sit it and they put
the giant copper weight that is concave
on top of it the pressure of the giant
copper waiters pushes down on the Isis
and the ice melts into a ball yes yes it
is exactly what you were just talking
about which happens when the skater is
on the ice you know what also happened
you could take a screen a grid like a
like a screen that would be on a screen
door but but just to
make this a little more interesting
increase the size of the grit of the the
screen whole good like maybe a half a
centimeter on a side and hold it
horizontally take a block of ice and
place it on this screen but it's got to
be really heavy ice and the screen is
not too fine a grid so what will happen
is the ice in contact with the screen
will feel the weight of the entire block
and it's going to melt it right it melts
it but just to get around this is
extreme right and it comes out on the
other side I'm I am melted ice at 31
degrees because I was under pressure but
now I'm back to 31 32 I mean 30 does it
say that right it melts in a in a below
freezing temperature and when it comes
out the other side is just freezing
because no longer under pressure under
pressure so you come back in a half hour
half of the block has passed through
this green but it's still I so many
others little ice on the other side Wow
and see this and all this happens when
you watch hockey and you don't even know
it speaking of skating and ice any tips
for skating anywhere else in the
universe
I urge does not have ownership of all
the ice so that's going on so Mars has
polar icecaps as does earth have to
shrink and grow seasonally as does Earth
and while we're there Mars rotates about
once every 24 hours hmm as deserve so
that's why Mars is such an object of our
affection as a possible second planet
that we might inhabit after we trash
earth but if you want to go beyond Mars
one of my favorite objects out there
celestial objects is a moon of Jupiter
called Europa rope I love me some Europa
this is far beyond the warm habitable
zone the Goldilocks zone where the
temperatures just right to sustain
liquid water to close if you have water
and you're too close to the Sun it
evaporates far away freeze ins Europa is
well outside of the zone but beneath
this surface of frozen water is a liquid
oceans been liquid for billions of years
it is an energy source from Jupiter
stressing the shape of Europa in ways in
ways that are not fundamentally
different from
if it played racquet sports and say
let's warm up the ball right yes yes yes
what are you doing you are compressing
the ball for every hit and then the ball
risk restores its shape ready for you to
smack it again ok pumping energy this is
through gravitational so what's
happening is what we call tidal forces
that distort the physical shape of
Europa and as Europa goes around Jupiter
it's then distorted in another way and
then in another way so it's constantly
getting getting harassed right by
Jupiter and other surrounding moons so
that collects as energy deep within and
it melts the ice so it's like when you
bend a paper clip back and forth back
and forth back and forth yes so he's oh
it's matter getting stressed and heat
and why does it get hot you're putting
energy into it by bending it back and
forth the different forms of energy into
your surrounding moons are conspiring to
make this happen ok so now watch so you
have a nice surface of ice on Europa in
principle you could go skating there
however this ice is not on top of a this
ice is not on top of a rigid surface as
a normal skating rink would be it's a
float and ocean so what happens the
ocean moves the ice cracks water seeps
up refreezes so there is no smooth Zam
bona fide surface right on Europa so I
don't know that escape I guess you could
bring a Zamboni there yeah that would be
a really wealthy civilization let's move
out Europa guys this is we go ice
skating on it we let's go Scrabble go
again
but more than wealthy but a quick thing
about Europa is of course I've said this
many times I want to go ice fishing on
Europa cut a hole and see if anything
swims did anything evolve in that ocean
for over the last billion years but
here's the thing ball games fold I know
yeah you watch what you wish for
but I'm colleagues if - that might not
be necessary because Europa keeps
breaking apart and refreezing when you
break apart the water gurgles up and
then refreezes very quickly ok because
it's a spontaneous crack 5 water so you
might be able to find
that got caught in the updraft of the
water right and so then you there and
it's just frozen fish right you didn't
have to dig for it it's in the cracks
right it's a TV dinner just wait for
your oppa TV drugs and food sick sex yet
frozen conversation there you go so so
it would be a very big challenge to
smooth that out and by the way the
surface of Europa looks just like what
the north polar regions used to be it's
ice sheets on an ocean because there's
no land in the North Pole contrary to
any representation of Santa you have
ever seen at home because you think they
have show pine trees around his is no
that doesn't use on the North Pole
he's on an ice floe and that he's no
different from the polar bear that's
about to be stranded because the ice is
melting right so that means there's
probably no reindeer up there either not
not only that he'll be overdressed for
the warm weather that's to come so in
the future he'll be Santa with fewer
clothes on and on the you sitting on the
ice floe so I don't want to ice you be
there next year for me all right don't
worry about that bad mr. sucks I didn't
mean to put that image in your head you
know on a beach chair or cat I was
working on his abs abs Dana as babies
it's not ads baby yeah oh there's also
another moon enceladus this is a fun
room because their pressures under the
surface and when we think of you always
yeah I think a Jellystone like yogi yes
thank you
Yellowstone Park with the geysers and
things like why they're geysers the
water gets heated a pressure builds up
it blows out sights oh oh okay so it
turns out after an earthquake it's not
faithful anymore that's what you haven't
heard about in last decades was last
time anyone even mentioned all faithful
to you think about it yeah so what I
read was there was an earthquake and it
messed with the under areas and now it's
just not faithful
it's still full blow so but not like
clap the way you yeah not the way you
say oh yeah so it's the old unfaithful
ha ha ha so so we've got so in sodus has
geysers and volcanoes that blow from the
pressure of evaporating ice
rather than from us the steam that we
build up from high temperatures so on
Enceladus
you've got geysers spewing hurling
chunks of ice right oh and volcanoes
that blow other check so the pressure is
from cold things subliming evaporate
like like co2 would the cold volcanoes
as a fun idea that's a great idea theme
park fascinating yeah yes
stop yeah it's got stuff it's back and
we're going to take a break more of
Neil's treats more of chucks discovery
of ice and a brain orgasm and me being
quiet probably learning lots of innocent
and vivid
Bank I'm Gary O'Reilly I'm certain I
this is playing with science before the
break we got a little bit glacial yes
and we learn plenty about ice water and
how I hate it how you cannot skate
without pressure melting the ice so that
you can glide on a little thin stream of
water fascinating stuff before and that
water refreezes immediately right the
other side because it's not the water is
not above the melting point you just
forced it into the liquid state under
pressure and that is healing that is
self-healing feeling I look at that yeah
and I'm sure that most people were under
the impression that you're just carving
through the ice and that's what makes
this skate or but that's amazing and
hence the way they sharpen the blade
right to make the Sinister on each side
and that's why in figure skating it's
that my daughter's figure skates and I
did a little bit of it long ago the most
of what they do is on one edge another
edge and as rarely are they ever just
going straight forward and it's all
about the curve because you're on the
edge and that's how your doubts how they
judge they do all the fun things yeah so
this is great let's move forward because
right now what if I just realized that
that this is just like the cheap-ass
show because like I'm in the family and
I'm your entire guest this whole show
yes what's the idea of some cheap huh
some people would look at that and
saying I'm that important this whole
shows about me you think a different
time guys are doing here I don't know
when I'm hosting a show me I get I'm
getting three people in a nod some from
around the world
Al Gore doesn't want to talk to us okay
all right all right I'll go out but he
was very short right select a little bit
all right let's go summertime before we
look at the tweet on baseball because
you had a really interesting tweet about
the slowest you could make a pitch which
made me think about in other words
there's a slowest possible pitch well as
possible pitch which can actually hit at
the physics of a slowest possible pitch
but it also got me thinking about one of
the most unique pitches in baseball
which is the knuckleball and there's a
guy by the name of RA Dickey who throws
the nastiest knuckleball in baseball so
let's take a look at this clip and and
then I just want you to comment on the
knuckleball for me and what I know
versus Boston
Boston versus Toronto and Dickies on the
mound and take it away the Blue Jays
because ra Dickey's throwing today josh
told he told me today he said trying to
catch the knuckleball is tough trying to
catch the knuckleball in the shadows on
a four o'clock game is nearly impossible
so we will watch that tomorrow for
Steven right yeah might be a proper Ryan
Hanigan the samarth will be back there
for Marcus Stroman well that was a
terrific humpable that would be that was
it comes an o1 pitch to a Blake's wired
and who is waived by Dave like Swihart
what just happened there I mean that
that was a funky delivery took a little
something off of it wiggling and then
watch the swing from Blake Swihart these
swings and see that just lets a good
hair nothing but air and so with a lot
of air wasn't like you just came near
the ball not only thing that wraps the
bat wrapped around his waist then flew
out of those control of it so but the
thing that made that interesting is will
you hear the announcer say the ball gets
to the plate and just Wiggles so what's
going on from a physics standpoint in
that instant so what we know from basic
physics 101 is it was physics 102 of
that work second semester second
semester is is this stability of an
object is improved and enhanced if you
rotate it yes you might have heard the
notion of something being spin
stabilized right yeah okay so it in NFL
but the spin stabilized so the spiral
goes and it's very stable in that in
that puts it's a crippled gyroscope
gyroscopes for example a planets are
stable spinning spinning objects so we
might spend a satellite to stabilize it
in its location so so alright a
knuckleball does not spin it is
therefore not spin stabilized and if
it's not spin stabilized it is
susceptible to any possible puffs of air
that goes
transverse to its path to the plate all
right
so the slightest breeze will just take
it hey and breezes are kind of its
strong in one instant and a little less
in another instant and and we just take
that for granted walking down the street
but it's not always constant in your
face give me an idea for one of our
little miniseries what a weird science
weird is that's weird because when we
see a pitch it does only weird if you're
unfamiliar with the science which people
are that's not as good as segments all
right it's not to do weird science with
this segment it's called it's only weird
if you're unfamiliar with people go
ahead so so a knuckleball so one thing I
would be interested in testing yeah is
if the air is perfectly still hmm
and I would I would wonder whether
knuckleballs in domed stadiums are as
effective as knuckle balls in the open
in open-air stadiums
you can have you know in any stadium
you've been in the air can just come in
and circle or as swirls the world's all
different kinds all kinds of different
things and now you do have air currents
in a closed dome because you have
air-conditioning ducts and they cycle
the eyes that are opening and close all
right so there's some there's some air
currents but I would be curious and I'm
sure the Sabre nutritions
you know the folks who calculate what
every little detail that has ever
happened in the history of baseball in
the universe maybe they have thought
about this I don't know but the I would
guess that in a closed stadium your
knuckleball just does not do as many
things as would otherwise do and and and
it also means if it's a windy day you
can't even trust the knuckleball because
the catcher will never catch it it'll
just go off one foot away in an
unpredictable way they're on the ball
every time if it's too windy it was too
windy you can't even it's it's a
crapshoot that's what's the worst will
happen if you'll catch it doesn't catch
it or if the batter doesn't hit it so
what would you rather if your catcher
doesn't if the people on base you don't
want to catch it and if it's if it's low
it matters it changes the dynamic
so the catcher doesn't catch it the
runner advances right and it's a it's a
passed ball so so you're Britt you know
the difference when you pass balls and
an error okay so
we have a Brit in the house so the
pitcher and the catcher handle the ball
on every single play right so they get
it they get a dispensation if they do
something wrong for the fact of handling
the ball in every single play so if I
the pitch and I throw the ball and it's
way outside you can't recover it and the
batter advanced it's not an error it's
called a wild pitch right right with you
and if I'm a catcher and I should have
caught the ball but I just mess up it's
called a pass ball ok those do not
accrue to your record of errors okay
whereas I'm a pitcher it hits back to me
and I throw to first base and I throw
over the guy's head era it's an error
all right I'm trying to catch the ball
I'm at home plate and it bounces off my
my web and goes over my head that's an
error so catchers tend to have a lot of
a lot of pass balls when they have
pitchers who throw knuckleball because
they cannot anticipate they cannot
anticipate where the ball is going to
anyway so with that in mind with that in
mind you wrote a really cool tweet about
baseball and we were just talking about
air currents this is just the opposite
so go ahead and read your tweet you
don't where's the tweet about the
minimum speed of a throw oh that's when
we do that yeah once we got the wrong
tweet up I'm sorry so here we go okay so
let me go into that so with that in mind
you wrote a tweet because the
knuckleball as you say is you know kind
of a subject to the whims of air current
and it'll tend to go very fast and they
don't tend to go very fast fastball
hitter you might just give up and go
back to the dugout right which which
brings me to this tweet that you wrote
about slow pitches yeah and so go ahead
and read this one okay slowest pitch in
baseball to reach the catcher 30 miles
per hour
thrown at a 45-degree angle any slower
and at any other angle it hits the
ground so that is the slowest possible
pitch and and and and so here's what's
funny about this what not funny here's
what I love about this sweet
and and working with you period is you
say a lot of things and people which I
appreciate
I appreciate that people go behind you
and actually it say okay I'm gonna see
if this is right well that's good but
the making trying to prove Tyson wrong
as a sport that's less than this more
difficult that can't be right let me
right right the great thing is there is
a guy which we don't have it it doesn't
make a difference he took your
calculations and diagrammed it out and
put it up on Twitter and with like Neil
deGrasse Tyson absolutely right this is
the absolute and it's the the actual
calculation is thirty point four miles
per hour grounded I rounded it but it's
thirty point four miles per hour thrown
from it has to be a 45-degree angle
factoring in the mound the mountain
ma'am is already factored in yeah and
the catcher is not actually at home
plate right in the arm of the pitcher
the ball leaves the hand of the pitcher
well forward of the of the rubber on the
mound okay so you gotta gotta put those
things so I did a rough estimate to that
is that he actually approved your
calculations in a diagram and put it up
on Twitter which I thought was fantastic
and that is that is the slowest you can
pinch a little pitch and the thing about
a 45 degree angle we all know what that
is it's equal amount forward as up and
you learn in physics 101 that it's an
interesting question how do I make by
the way this comes from military
military Napoleon Napoleon addition in
Napoleon's library yeah on Elba when he
was there an entire wall of engineering
and physics books mm-hmm so he wasn't
just a little tyrannical guy he knew who
he knew not only how to make his cannon
he knew where the cannibal was gonna
listen you got to know where to put
those cannonballs if you want to rule
the world no way but your balls go right
if you want to hit your enemy as far
away as they are what angle should you
put your cannon right and you can
calculate that angle for a given speed
of the ball coming out of the nozzle
whatever the whole 45 degrees if you
angle it higher than that you're wasting
some of the speed in altitude rather
than in distance
if you angle it lower than 45 degrees it
doesn't stay airborne long enough to go
as far as it could have right 45 degrees
maximizes the the hang time and the
distance so that you can go as far as
you possible possibly can on that hit
now if they're closer than that maximum
distance then you want to adjust the
height so the what do you call those
things that they go boom boom
they take Moses did more yeah those were
sales yeah yeah so that's a fixed speed
that it comes out and if they're not as
far away at the maximum speed you got to
change the angle higher right and then
then so that's how you do it that does
what the first compute might use for
sweet spot of war right so you apply
that same calculation to a pitch you get
you get a 45 degree angle 30 mile an
hour pitch sweet man I just thought that
was really interesting
that's why sometimes they have people
first pitch ceremonial first pitches
right sometimes people throw it it just
never makes it so home plate right
because they throw that 28.4 miles an
hour and if you ever wanted to have the
evidence of meal thinking deeply about
his tweets before he tweets them that's
exactly it that's it you've sat there
you've calculated sort about it and just
to be clear it's not that I distracted
my day to make that tweet I just had
that thought anyway yeah then I said
well let me make it rigorous with the
calculation so that did take extra time
but this was a thought I was having
anyway while I was watching a baseball
game cool all right let's get to I
probably will be our last tweet what do
we have for the segment okay Rick stop
mm-hmm oh you can play baseball on the
airless moon but only if you find a way
to not suffocate okay and if you don't
care about curve balls right yeah
because a curve ball requires a
difference in pressure at one side of
the ball to the other to have air alter
the course of that of that ball and
curve it like beckham or what something
like that I'm mad at Ben D Beckham
that's no different from what he's doing
on when he can kick it forward but with
a spin he's relying on the aerodynamics
of the ball moving through the air for
the air didn't push the ball sideways
looking like it has some magic arc to it
but it's really just aerodynamics
yeah it's like it's the aerodynamic
version of putting English on the ball
when you play billiards right they call
it putting English on the ball in the UK
was it putting American on the balls yes
yes okay that's very cool very cool I
think we have time for one more quick
one all right let's do it
can we do a quick one if it's super
quick apparently we can I can do I can I
know how to be a soundbite er it's not
my preference but I can soundbite is she
talking to you guys okay
okay she saw her sister want to end it
on this alright so uh do we have it up
that we run over enough to make up for
this we're good so okay so then all
right well Neil I got to tell you man
this was fantastic how much fun we
didn't get through most of my tweets all
we did have to come back and do it all
again okay I'll be a cheap date for you
guys you already in the Bartok family
just call me up and I come by because
I'm a sucker for the stage yeah well we
certainly appreciate it man seriously
that was a lot of fun very informative
and you know a little different twist on
the show so we're glad that we did it
all right
and Gary O'Reilly you're Chuck nice this
has been playing with science but if you
think about it we've spun the playing
with science just a little bit
differently so thank you to Neil
deGrasse Tyson who has been entertaining
as always informative and a great sport
for going back through all of those
tweets over the recent years thank you
from us on playing with science so you
will soon
you